uh
there's a black
Market okay uh
okay does that look okay
uh yeah if you can uh slide that black
block a little further but uh
okay dude just close the chat then
although if you close the chat then
you'll be able to
okay
people oh okay okay okay
so uh uh great for uh Alistair to be uh
joining us talking about uh
collaborations with Tony so take it away
Alistar okay very good uh does the
screen look okay yeah
okay
all right
so
sound okay
yes sound is okay yes yes okay
all right um
I'm sorry I wasn't able to uh
participate uh
in person I was originally intending to
um but uh unfortunately
I erect my back
um so it was impossible
uh but I'm sorry I couldn't uh
couldn't uh
take part but only virtually it's okay
so at least I'm glad to take part uh
take part in the celebration for Tony
um
the uh the reason I wrecked my
wrecked my back was uh
was uh
oops
what is this little animal a cat me to
uh and uh he has a habit of
crapping on the rug when he doesn't get
his litter box cleaned so uh we uh
thought we'd better
get some more
kitty litter and then when we were in
Costco I
lifted a 50-pound box of kitty litter
and
result was a disaster so
there you go
so you can blame it on meeting or I
suppose or
at 77 years old I think I'm a bit a bit
too old for lifting 50 pound boxes
anyway
let's continue
I thought I'd begin with um
looking at my own neighborhood in the
collaboration graph and as you can see I
have a lot of
collaborated with a lot of people over
the years
um
20.
and uh but the person with whom I've
collaborated most is Tony
as you can see there's five
collaborations here and I'll excuse me
I'll talk about them
uh as part of the talk
uh
this uh graph here or my neighborhood in
the graph
also shows that I have an urdish number
of four
let me see one two three
no sorry three three is better Tony is
lucky enough to have a narrative number
of uh two but uh I managed to have
an Earnest number of three through Tony
okay
so there's all my uh
collaborations
with people and uh had a lot of fun over
the years
uh the most important uh
about a lot of collaborations with uh
very talented logicians and
mathematicians over the years but the
most important of these collaborations
was undoubtedly with with Tony
um I've I've had more collaborations
with Tony than anybody else and uh
there are also very intense
collaborations as we'll see
um
so
moving on
my first collaboration I I forget I
can't even remember exactly how I came
to know Tony I must have been
attending one of the classes in computer
science I must have got to know Tony at
that point and we got got going on a
collaboration
I uh I started out in philosophy uh
and I was interested in uh all kinds of
weird stuff like uh Hegel
she doesn't sound very logical but
that was you know where I started from
Wally is kind of very Misty mystical
stuff
but then I read Bertrand Russell and uh
the introduction to mathematical
philosophy and that kind of
turned my head around so
that's how I got into logic
but I started off in non-classical logic
not classical logic
and uh
so I spent oh I don't know I went to
Pittsburgh where uh Anderson and Velma
Alan Anderson and the new bell lab
knew it was my thesis advisor
um Alan Anderson and uh renewable that
we're working on relevance logic so of
course I ended up working on that
although I always wanted to be a
classical magician not a non-classical
magician so but and you know
that's just history
so I worked I worked in that area for uh
I don't know
decade or two
but I still felt uh I kind of lack
namely I always wanted to um
I always wanted to collaborate with
people you know and and
the Toronto philosophy Department
actually didn't have any other logician
at the time it has a few now but at the
time it didn't have any so uh
it was kind of frustrating you know I
was a bit cut off
and then I discovered this um that uh
the computer scientists particularly
around Toronto were working on classical
logic particularly the complexity of
satisfiability problems so I thought
haha this is this is a way to go and uh
I made a move into computer science even
though I started off in this completely
different place namely
um philosophy and philosophical logic
and so on non-classical logic so anyway
it was a great it was a great move so
not only did Toronto have a great
faculty
in computer science they also had
wonderful graduate students and here's
two of The Graduate students with whom I
collaborated at the time
Tony you all know uh Steve you may not
all of you may know Steve Bellantoni
he's he's moved on to uh Finance
you work in financial sector but it was
a really great collaborator too
anyway uh so what did we do here
uh
there was a big breakthrough around this
time when I was sitting in computer
science classes
probably one of the biggest
breakthroughs in computer science around
that time namely Mickey I ties
proof that of super polynomial
lower bounds for the pigeonole principle
and I spent ages studying this paper and
so did Tony and Steve it's a very
difficult paper it's very challenging
uh what what Mickey I tie does I mean
the guy's a genius but his papers are I
have to say very hard to read but
um
anyway the way the way the thing is
proved is that you start from a
a
non-standard model of number Theory and
then you force over you do forcing over
this non-standard model so it's a hard
proof to understand
so we had uh
we had two
two things that we wanted to do
the two things that we wanted to do were
to first of all
try to get a standard proof of this risk
result
and then secondly try to prove improve
the uh Mickey High ties proof to
exponential
we succeeded in the the first
goal but not in the second so that was a
we we got a super polynomial bound using
standard techniques but it didn't
succeed in
in getting an exponential order and we
thought we thought we did have one at
first but then that turned out to be a
bust
so partial partial success but not
complete success
so
the Tony Tony persisted as you all know
and eventually managed to um
get the exponential bound that we were
after
um with uh Paul Beeman wrestling payaso
and uh
Jan krach
and Alan Woods did it independently so
this was a an amazing
achievement and uh so great work
uh what I what I think this is um I
think this was probably the most intense
collaboration of my career
um
I was working on the uh Bertrand Russell
papers at the time and I remember
driving back and forth to uh Hamilton to
visit the Russell archives and as I was
driving back and forth I would
think about the original principle which
was a big problem
but uh anyway that was that was a very
intense collaboration and very enjoyable
so let's see uh
these are the sort of pictures we spent
a lot of time drawing when we were
talking talking and
people's offices drawing these uh kind
of pictures of
um
Wi-Fi type graphs but you're going n
plus one on one side and n on the other
and uh
so this this was sort of uh
how we thought about the problem we I
remember spending ages looking at these
uh pictures
I remember I remember Tony actually got
fed up having to make it n plus one and
a and she said why don't we just make an
n and n in one second and the other
simplifies the picture
I think it's probably not a bad idea
anyway there's the uh there's a
fictional principle which I'm sure
you're all familiar with
and so you got the negative Clauses
positive Clauses and so on
okay
and uh the uh the lower bound the
standard lower bound not the one you do
using non-standard models is done using
decision trees
so it's the
decision tree model and you're you're
assigning formulas
um decision trees
and uh then you want to
use a random restriction to get uh lower
the depth that's the basic idea
uh the the reason we weren't able to get
a an exponential lower bound is that we
were following Mickey I tie at that
point
and uh he he uses
decision trees that are over a small set
of nodes okay and that that won't give
you an exponential lower Bound in fact
the paper that I wrote with
Steve and Tony explains why it doesn't
work
uh the
the improved exponential lower bound
comes from using not
decision trees over small sets of nodes
but rather small depth decision trees
that's the key okay
so anyway Tony and uh Paul and Russell
got this great result and so all of this
I think it illustrates one of Tony's
outstanding qualities namely persistence
and pursuing a problem
things
after after we'd failed to prove a
exponential lower Bound for the pigeon
principle I gave up and uh
Steve moved on to other things including
he actually was interested in the
postmodern philosophy which I I didn't
find that crazy interesting but Steve
had quite a thing about Steve Valentini
and a bit of a thing about
post-modern philosophy anyway that's not
sad different question anyway Tony
continued and eventually succeeded and
how it goes to show in her determination
to succeed in solving the problem
so great work
all right so that's the pigeonhole
principle uh partial success and uh my
uh collaboration with Tony and Steve was
as I say probably the most intense of my
career
collaboration
uh this was upper and lower bounds for
tree light cutting planes
uh
I can't honestly say hi I'm glad really
contributed a lot to this
um Tony and Russell did the
did the really heavy work heavy lifting
here uh the only thing I contributed was
an upper Bound for um
grass with a no perfect matching that's
the only thing I contributed so I'll
I'll pass on too
other collaborations where I think I it
managed to contribute something
here's the hayash calculus or hayash
construction from graph Theory
so what is this Construction
it's a way of it's a kind of proof
system
for generating
non-k colorable graphs okay
I think it was invented in the first
place with the hope of
solving the Four Color problem at that
time
but as far as I know it's never made any
useful contribution in that area but
it's an interesting calculus
so here's the here's the calculus so
think of it as a proof system for graphs
the axioms this is for um
non
uh three color ability okay so so you're
trying to generate all non-free
colorable graphs
so your axioms are K4 copies of K4
and the rule the basic rule the highest
row
is this you you take two graphs so here
we've got two
uh
k4s and we identify these two
nodes here these two vertices
and then having identified the two
vertices you eliminate
these two edges
and then we add a new Edge along the top
okay and you also have a real
that says you can add
um vertices and edges ad-lib okay so
it's corresponds to the real weakening
in propositional logic
oh
so why were we interested in this well
first of all I I kind of like graphical
stuff like pictures
but another thing is uh
that uh
there was an interesting graph there
graph theorists were interested in this
calculus because they wanted to know
how complex the derivations had to be
um bjorni Toft uh had suggested a
he suggested a
uh a sequence of graphs that are not
three colorable but it's not obvious how
to prove them using the Irish calculus
so
how did we but in fact it turns out they
they do have
feasible proofs
and the way we proved that was
the way we proved it was by showing that
the uh
the highest calculus is in a certain
sense equivalent to
extended extended fragrance system
or extended resolution same thing
um
I think it turns so it turns out that
the
the calculus is actually very powerful
it's a it's a very powerful system
and uh
it also allows you to show very easily
that certain sequences of graphs are
actually quite easy to prove in the
calculus because of the result of Steve
Cook it's a very old but a very deep
result
that if there's a feasibly constructed
proof
that a sequence of graphs is uh sorry if
you have a sequence of
pathologies rather that for which
there's a feasibly constructed proof
that the
that they're contradictory
then
then there's short extended fragrant
proofs or feasibly feasible size
fragrance extended fragrance proofs okay
now what we did was we uh we showed that
uh
the highest calculus is in a certain
sense
uh equivalent to Extended Fraga so what
does this mean it means that the
examples that were cooked up by
yarny Toft
in fact since the proof that these are
not three colorable is uh
feasibly constructive it shows that
there are short extended fragrant proofs
of the corresponding
formulas logical formulas enhance that
there's a short
um
calculus proof okay so that's the result
I think it was a nice result I was quite
pleased with it uh fortunately
Tony was she was still a graduate
student at the time and she did all the
real hard work
you know the Translating back and forth
between graphs and uh logic is is
actually quite kind of you have to
encode things in the right way
and fortunately Tony was I left all the
heavy lifting was really really done by
Tony
um I think I contributed something but
uh I have to say I think this is place
where Tony did an awful lot of the work
and I'm very grateful for that so anyway
I think it's a nice result and quite
pleasing
okay so that's the highest calculus and
I think it was a nice paper that I did
with Tony there
all right
uh fourth collaboration was with uh
Tony and Noriko Ari
and that was complexity of analytic
tableau
the uh the complexity of analytics have
low as compared to uh
you may not be too familiar with
analytic Tableau but it's been
people involved in automatic automated
theorem proving actually have used
Tableau quite a bit and there's there's
a
series of conferences on analytic
analytic Tableau
um so it's it's something that interests
people
anyway uh there's an old there's an old
collection of examples uh due to Steve
Cook I think
and uh they're based on
trees
okay
and so
the way you look at it is this you look
here's you you label the internal nodes
of the tree with uh variables
and then if you go left you have a
a positive thing so Q here and if you go
right you have a not Cube and okay so
there's your set of disjunctions
and uh these separate causal Tableau
clauso means that you you explode the
you explode the each disjunction each
Clause is exploded completely
now these separate colossal Tableau from
from treat resolution
however uh it was pointed out by Fabio
masachi that if you formulate
uh Tableau with binary decomposition so
you're
see if you look at the uh
at the various literals here you can see
the ones if you're getting closer to the
the leaves
the uh the literals at the leaves are
less and less significant the one at the
at the root is quite significant but
then it gets less and less significant
as you go towards the leaves
and the result is
um if when you look at the the place
where you've exploded the
one of these Clauses okay so so let's
say this not P or not R and what other
Clauses not p e r or not s
if you
look at the subtree that has this
let's say s or not s
you have to keep basically repeating a
whole mass of stuff so that's why you
can't simulate
um
tree resolution efficiently but Fabio
Versace pointed out that if you
formulate Tableau with binary decal
position where you give preference to
the more significant look for nodes then
you can get an exponential speed up
and uh so uh with Tony and narico we
gave up
there's various ways of
formulating analytic Tableau one is the
causal way
the other is you can just do kind of
arbitrary decompositions you can just
drop drop a
a clause into bits arbitrarily and we
give a pretty complete analysis of the
possibilities there so
that was my
um and actually
um
you can show that uh
you could there's actually a
quasi-polynomial
uh simulation
of tree resolution by this system okay
so that was uh that was the analytic
Tableau work that I did with Tony
and Noriko
this collaboration uh this was this was
a lot of fun too uh I remember
spending
many happy hours in second cup with Tony
and uh Jan Johansson working on an
exponential separation between regular
and general resolution
uh my my favorite Clauses uh my favorite
examples for uh resolution were always
the Satan Clauses that's that's where I
started my work in proof complexity
actually was with the Satan causes
and um
uh I I recommend by the way a very nice
survey paper by Tony and Noah Fleming on
the Satan classes very nicely written
survey with all the stuff about Satan
clauses
but if you look at uh if you look at the
Satan Clauses the graph based clauses
the the
it looks as if the bass proofs are
always regular that is to say they you
never query a variable
more than once in a given strand of the
proof tree so it's like a read one's
branching program
so I was sort of convinced that regular
resolution was uh was optimal but of
course it's completely false it's
totally false and uh
but uh anyway we we worked hard on that
and we did eventually manage to get the
uh
get an exponential lower bound
um separation between regular and
general so that was nice work and I
enjoyed working with Jan and Tony
um there's still an open problem there
which as far as I know is unsolved
namely
um
to prove or disprove that regular
refutations are minimal for the Satan
clauses I kind of think that's true
but I don't know how to prove it but
it's a rather special question but I
think that's kind of an interesting
question or more generally
um
for what sets of clauses
are regular refutations minimum and I
think it's true for the Satan Clauses if
you could solve it for the Satan clauses
I think you'd have a general proof but
uh I work I work off and on on this
problem but uh
never succeeded in cracking it but uh I
recommend it if you're interested in
kind of rather specialized problems in
and out in resolution
well let's see what's the time 340 I
think I'm
I started a little late but I think
probably uh
probably I should stop there
um I apologize for I should hope to make
a better better talk but I really was
flattened my back for about two two
weeks and if you notice I'm kind of
um channeling my inner Steve Bannon so
let me apologize for that
uh so uh I think I'll stop there and uh
wish Tony a happy birthday and thanks so
much for uh being my collaborator on
lots of interesting projects and it was
great fun and uh many happy returns Tony
thank you
hi Aleister it's Tony that was great
thanks Tony I just wanted to say that
the as a grad student going and spending
time with Aleister and his office or
wherever it was truly amazing so many
good problems to work on just handed
them to me and then would spend forever
he'd go seamlessly between you know
talking about philosophy talking about
classical logic non-classical most of
the time at that time I didn't know much
of anything but it was he was patient
and it was super fun and yeah it was
also yeah super special time for me so
thank you I have I have a question for
you so all of the time that we toiled
um with you know
trying to turn it as beautiful proof
into a standard proof yeah in retrospect
I feel like maybe that was a big mistake
um uh because we can't we don't know how
to do that yet you know even with one
level of mod Gates do you have any
thoughts on that oh yeah sorry explain
the problem again well it's more of a
question so I'm saying I tie had this
brilliant idea of how to use
non-standard model Theory
because you know we were stuck from the
get-go with just the fact that you know
all the lines in a fragrant proof are
the constant ones so like semantically
it's kind of you have to do something
really different right than normal
circuit methods we spent all that time
to make it standard which I guess led to
the improved exponential bound but it
took some Focus away from I think in my
mind like the you know the the power of
the thinking like I thinking in a
non-standard model and in particular we
don't know how to prove level
with Mod Gates so just wondering if you
what you think
yeah I I haven't thought about these
problems for for ages
um yeah and cry check would be probably
be the best person to you know give you
an idea there
um I agree it's we were puzzled at first
uh you know how do you how do you get a
lower bound when everything is it's a
selfish it's bizarre question
um and I think the answer really is that
uh basically you're dealing with a
non-classical logic
the models that you have
are in essence non-classical
um
so you know you can have decision trees
that falsify a tautology I mean this is
what's happening in the uh pigeonhole
proof
uh so yeah it's a good question I I
don't know the answer to it but uh I
think it's kind of funny that when I was
working with you and Steve on these
problems I realized that I kind of come
full circle I wasn't it started off in
non-classical logic but in a certain
sense to get lower bands for bound to
depth Fraga systems or I guess for
fragrance systems generally
you have to have non-standard models I
mean how else you're going to falsify a
tautology right you have to have a model
in which
um you know as long as the proof isn't
too big you can make the uh axioms true
and then falsify the thing you're trying
to do
we have a lower Bound for it that's at
least that's the way I think about it
now but and I don't think I'm the right
person to answer that question uh yeah
yeah and would be the right one I think
yeah credit check
thanks thanks for the great talk too
thank you
yes thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
so uh so we're going to reconvene at 2
30 again with uh a number of uh Tony
students who will be uh speaking and we
have many uh great talks uh this
afternoon so uh best to get out while
the weather is is still good and uh and
get some one so
oh yes and and a reminder again so after
the after the 5 p.m talk
there will be a special event upstairs
here at the simus Institute so not on
this floor but up one floor the doors
are normally locked but we'll have them
open so that everybody can come up and
so please don't go away we have a lot
lots more to do after after 5 p.m uh
today and for those on Zoom we will have
a a zoom uh virtual Zoom uh uh session
for that as well
thank you thanks again
[Applause]